dude this guy hit on me at my gym he was
like hey man would you workout today and
I was like I work out my shoulders and
my back and he was like a cool man it's
so tiring his dong was in full view he's
completely naked his [ __ ] pigeon was
out you know and he had so much so many
pubes - it looked like his dick was
hiding he looked like his dick was in
Vietnam you ever see somebody with such
fierce pubes that it looks like his dick
was in Vietnam I can see a guy who's
[ __ ] dude if your pubes are longer
than your [ __ ] dick what those aren't
pubes those are banana leaves dude
you're in Vietnam you're in Nam dude any
time I see a guy whose pubes are longer
than his [ __ ] dick I want to be like
oh dude you're in Nam
and this guy's dick was so in Vietnam
dude he was like he was like hey man so
what you work out and I was like
shoulders and back and he was like and
that was when I noticed his dick was in
Vietnam and I was like oh [ __ ] and
[Laughter]